America's worst lawyers going down the
way he came in after making a name for
himself trashing the president Michael
avenatti is now claiming Trump is to
blame for his new wave of legal troubles
he believes his indictment yesterday is
a product of political revenge
it has quote Trump's fingerprints all
over it
avenatti facing multiple federal charges
and a maximum of 400 years in prison and
we can't forget about the liberal media
looking like fools after putting
avenatti on TV 254 times in the year
leading up to all this here's a quick
look back
he's Donald Trump's worst nightmare my
god joining us once again is Michael
avenatti that's bringing Michael
avenatti
Michael avenatti Michael Lebanon Michael
avenatti thank you very much he's out
there saving them says he may be the
savior of the Republic you are something
of a folk hero now Michael avenatti and
apology I've been saying enough already
Michael I've seen you everywhere what do
you have love to say I was wrong brother
you have a lot to say we think you guys
are the tip of the spear that's going to
take down Donald Trump let's get into
his head for a second okay what makes
him say do you think that he believes
that Trump is responding he's about
twenty eight days away from an insanity
defense yeah really it is bizarre yeah
pretty much like look look at all of the
evidence and there's no strategy behind
like really is Donald Trump responsible
for the fact that he defrauded the
client that was a disabled yeah that was
years before the trial no I think like
the the DOJ has very good lawyers who
suss this out early on the media did not
has the media said anything about the
latest development it is pathetic how
quiet they are I was I mean Stephanie
ruhle should address what you she called
him brother isn't that sweet he's a scum
and she's they date embrace him you know
why big actually it's to his credit he
showed everyone how easy it is to
commandeer the media and exploit their
weaknesses and what were their
weaknesses a desperate need to handicap
Trump and ruin Cavanaugh so he was there
to get to to do CNN's and MSNBC his
dirty work he jumped on that horse and
wrote it to the
they're like guests heap and but they
should I think they have they have a
responsibility to address their mistakes
I have done that when I make a mistake I
always time you Jessi you do it almost
every single day I had a good point oh
he said he heard that Trump was had his
finger prints all over it from from a
Republican close to Trump
there's no Republican sort of talking to
avenatti there's nobody I mean he's a
full-grown liar and he's getting he's
getting 400 years which I didn't I mean
he's he's not the Taliban to your point
about owning up to mistakes let's just
say to someone I have on waters world a
lot let's say Sebastian Gorka let's say
Sebastian Gorka was hit with multiple
felony charges this is an analogy and
he's been on my show multiple times over
the course of the last two years don't
you think I would take a moment to
address the fact that you could minimize
over hours maybe he was involved in
something and I maybe Shelton you
shouldn't use such a made-up name needs
to take ownership of this a little bit
you would do the same look you know
wasn't just CNN it was on an Anna
Navarro and the view was saying that he
was like the Holy Spirit yes pay her
said that he was saving the country and
I think to your theory about him saying
it's Trump's fault whether there's a
strategy there if he says it's Trump's
fault the media will jump down have some
good at nd for him and he's delusional
the actor small right well I I'm so
surprised at all of you blaming the
media I don't I think every media in
America thought this was a salacious
case in which he was representing a porn
star who claimed to have he still affair
with the president a man who turned out
to be President and then it turned out
that there was a payoff to the porn star
and a check signed by the president
United States now if you're a journalist
and you don't cover that you're negative
but that's what
absolutely cover that okay but that
doesn't mean then you say that he is
next to Jesus Savior you are the lawyer
for the person lawyer and he gets on TV
the check shows up the check is signed
by Donald Trump gee I think some of the
evidence show that's why they fell for
him we want they love that story so they
fell for him no no what you're saying is
they're anti Trump and that's why but
I'm saying I don't care who the
president was Bill Clinton and Monica
Lewinsky Donald it's not wrong to say
put Michael avenatti put the lawyer it's
not even just that it's yes it's
newsworthy he's representing someone in
the storm of Daniels case the problem is
that the media then took him and made
him a celebrity expert lawyer in the
Kavanaugh case and he tried to destroy
Brett Cavanaugh's life by accusing him
of gang rape with no evidence and then
he was referred by the Senate Judiciary
Committee for criminal charges for lying
to investigators on both sides of the
political aisle so it didn't just stop
with the case about stormy Daniels which
sure newsworthy they then extended it to
smear a Supreme Court nominee no but I
was no evidence at all but now their
knowledge izing are going back through
the other story Katie we didn't know at
the time that he was up to he was
leaving the trail of dysfunction
wherever you went all we mass is
arrested he was arrested during that
time remember no but I'm saying he was
on TV and he was a member I don't know
if he's still a member of the bar kicked
out his law firm back then but you guys
because you want to discredit anybody
who we don't have to discredit him
you're doing it retroactively Lee you're
saying oh they should have known we were
here ashes no actually to your point we
deserve credit for calling out Alvin Adi
what was happening and especially dr.
Carlson who called him the creepy porn
lawyer at the height of his fame
remember he said he's a creepy porn
lawyer and he got vindicated so I think
Tucker deserves a pat on the back and
everybody else is CNN Emma City they
should come forward and say what they
did wrong Stephanie ruhle that wasn't
very nice and Sebastian I apologize